good afternoon today I'm presenting my
annual report for 2022
and this report sons of
the main activity activities of our
Reliance
in the last year
2022 was a pivotal year for our security
versus illegal war against Ukraine is
now entering its second year
President Putin made a big strategic
mistake when he invaded Ukraine
he expected the Kiev would fall within
days and a whole of Ukraine within weeks
but he underestimated the Steely
resistance of Ukrainian people
he told he could break NATO Unity but
NATO allies are standing strong and
enlightened and providing 100 support
for Ukraine
and he wanted less NATO but he has got
exactly the opposite more neighbor
in response to Russia's illegal War
Finland and Sweden decided to apply for
NATO membership
which will double the length of NATO's
border with Russia
at the NATO Summit in Madrid last June
all allies took the historic decision to
invite Finn and Sweden to join
both countries have addressed turkey's
legitimate 6 50 concerns and delivered
on the equipments under the collateral
memorandum agreed in Madrid
tortilla is now ready to ratify
finland's membership of NATO
I welcome that decision and I look
forward to the Grand National Assembly
ratifying Finance accession before the
upcoming Turkish general election
I also welcome that the Hungarian
Parliament will vote on Finland next
week
the most important thing is that both
Finland and Sweden become full members
of NATO quickly not whether they join at
exactly at the same time
and I will continue to work hard to
ensure that Sweden becomes a full member
as soon as possible
because the exception of Finland and
Sweden will make them safer Our Lives
stronger and demonstrate that NATO's
door remains open
15 wants a different Europe he sees
democracy and freedom as effect and he
seeks to control its neighbors
so even if the war in Ukraine ended
tomorrow the security environment has
changed for the long term
Putin's Invasion last year was a shock
but it was not a surprise
it was the culmination of a pattern of
aggressive action
and in response since Russia's illegal
annexation of Korea in 2014 NATO has
implemented the largest reinforcement or
Collective defense in a generation
parents rolled into Ukraine we were
ready
within hours we activated our defense
fans from the Baltic to the Black Sea we
put 40 000 troops in the NATO command
with a significant air and Maritime
crisis and doubled the number of native
bat groups from four to eight
at the same time NATO unless I provide
in Ukraine with significant support
Supply and advanced weapon systems and a
mission to help Ukraine defend itself
and regain territory
we are also in the process of agreeing a
new capability targets for the
production of battle decisive ammunition
and engaging with industry to ramp
operation
to support Ukraine against Russia's
aggression after our own defense
NATO is increasing the protection of
critical National infrastructure
including undersea cables and Parklands
we are set up an undersea infrastructure
connection cell here at NATO
headquarters and established a joint
NATO EU task force
at our Summit in Madrid last June NATO
unless agreed
a further fundamental shift in other
terms and defense
we knew plants assigning specific forces
to this to defend specific allies
hiredness more stocks and more
prepositioned equipment and even
stronger command and control
Arrangements
we agreed a new strategic concept the
first in a decade to guide our lines in
an era of strategic competition
it identifies Russia as the most
significant threat to our security along
with the ongoing Federal terrorism
and makes clear that China Challenge our
interests security
values
2022 was the eighth consecutive year of
increased defense spending across Europe
and Canada
last year defense spending increased by
2.2 percent in real terms
since allies agreed the defense
investment pledge in 2014 European
allies and Canada has spent an
additional 350 billion extra on the
events
many allies have also announced
significant defense spending increases
since Russia's invasion
now these fetches must turn into real
cash contracts and concrete equipment
because defense spending
underpins everything we do
since 2014 allies have increased defense
spending and we are moving in the right
direction
but they're not moving as fast as the
dangerous role we live in the mountains
so while I welcome all the progress that
has been made it is obvious that we need
to do more and we need to do it faster
afterwards some of the buildings in July
I expect allies to agree and more
ambitious new defense investment pledge
with two percent of GDP as a minimum to
be invested in our events
in this new and more contested world we
cannot take our security for granted
it is our security that underpins our
prosperity and our way of life
our latest polling shows that 82 percent
of people across the 30 neglamas believe
it is important that North America and
Europe work together for our shared
security
and 61
agree that negative membership makes an
attack from a foreign Nation less likely
NATO has enabled Europe and North
America to live in peace for almost 75
years
but today's world is as dangerous as at
any time see the Second World War
the years to come will be challenging
and Nathan must continue to rise to the
challenge
of that I'm ready to take your questions
as Secretary General can you tell us how
many countries are currently meeting the
two percent Target according to your
latest reports
um and if that number is still
relatively small as a part of the total
um can you comment on do you have any
concerns about the fact that even
um almost 10 years after that gold was
agreed
my allies aren't meeting that Target
we have all the numbers and the figures
uh updated in this report both
graphically but also in the tables where
you can enter the details for each and
every Ally and it shows that seven
allies now spend the two percent uh we
actually expected that to be slightly
more earlier but because GDP has
increased more than expected for a
couple hours two hours that are expected
to be able to presented housewife they
belong two percent
um so as I said we welcome the progress
we welcome the fact that all allies have
increased a little more hours now spend
a few percent of GDP on the events and
more and more allies are actually coming
closer to two percent having said that
there's no doubt that we need to do more
and we need to do it faster the pace we
have when it comes to increase the
transpending is not high enough enough
um so my message to analyze is that our
welcome what I've done but I need to
speed up they need to deliver more in
emotional world you need to invest more
there in the events and that of course
it is important that allies needed to
some guideline but of course it also
helps that those allies are being close
to one percent now are at 1.5 we're
moving towards two percent so for
instance in Germany has significant
increased defense
defense over the last years they're
still not at two percent uh but the
increase in German defense spending
really it makes a big difference because
of the share volume of the German
economy and the German defense budget
and Germany has clearly committed
from the Associated Press you um you
just met with a Hungarian foreign
minister and I understand from some
remarks that he's made in in Brussels
that you intend to go ahead with a uh a
ministerial level
um meeting at some point uh mango
Ukraine and I wondered why you've made
that decision to go ahead uh despite
what I understand to be existing
Hungarian objections and if I put
briefly I'd be very interested in any
remarks you might have about the Chinese
peace plan
that President XI and uh and president
putinato
first one of the peace plan
it is for Ukraine to
what are acceptable conditions uh for
any peaceful solution
and China therefore leads to start to
understand Ukraine's perspective and to
engage with president zelensky at Dollar
Tree if it's uh if it wants to be
serious about peace and we also need to
remember that China has not been able to
condemn the illegal War a Russian Russia
against Ukraine
uh having said that
of course I will welcome any initiative
any plan that
that sustainable piece
China's peace proposal includes some
positive aspects Anonymous which I
support
for instance the importance of nuclear
safety of protection of civilians and at
least
underlying the importance of sovereignty
tele integrity and Independence and of
course any peace a solution for Ukraine
must be based on these principles to the
respect of the territory Integrity
uncertainty of of Ukraine and this is
also the main element of the peace plan
that president selinski put forward some
months ago and of course any endurable
lost MPS has to respect Ukraine as a
certain independent nation in Europe in
accordance with the U.N Charter
and a ceasefire or any solution that
doesn't respect the 17th and theater
Integrity of Ukraine
will only be a way to freeze the war and
to ensure that Russia can reconstitute
the UE group and re-attack
and that will not be uh just
unsustainable peace it will only help
Russia to hold on to territory it has
illegally occupied so again I welcome
initiatives that can lead to just
unsustainable peace and the other day
has to be of the Ukraine to decide what
are the acceptable conditions or what we
should do is to support Ukraine in the
right to defend themself all right which
is to try and the human shelter and they
are defending oneself themselves against
Russia's illegal war or aggression then
on
on the NATO Ukraine commission yes my
plan is to convince a meeting
at our foreign ministerial meeting a
couple of weeks I do so because I think
this is a platform to
demonstrate our
support to to Ukraine Ukraine is
enhanced opportunity partner but at the
same time I'm aware of the issues
related to minority so this is an issue
that has also been discussed directly
with Ukraine in previous meeting and I
guess that will continue to be
unexpected
thank you very much Secretary General
you mentioned that you will be
advocating for a more ambitious defense
investment pledge I was wondering if you
could share perhaps a bit of detail of
what you would be advocating for at
Vilnius would it be again a 10-year
pledge will the numbers still be two
percent just as a four or would you be
advocating for a different number thank
you
so first of all
it has to be or it will be up to a third
hour so
to decide what will be other the
language of a new uh defense investment
pledge but I will work for an I will
advocate in favor of more ambitious
attached
made in 2014 and simply because yes the
war starts in 2014 with the legalization
of Crimea and Russia going into
istanbulance but of course the
full-fledged Invasion that we saw last
February has made it difficult and
dangerous and and and challenge the
equity is more dangerous and even more
challenging so if there was a need to
increase defense spending back in 2014
this is even more obvious now and um and
and of course we also have to build on
the progress we have made back in 2014
uh uh the majority of Allah reducing
their uh defense budgets it total
defense spending across Europe and
Canada was going down year four years so
we're on the downward Trend and only
three allies has spent the two percent
or more on on the fence since 2014 those
pictures hope they changed now all ours
have increased defense spending
um and uh and and in totality uh we now
have eight consecutive years of uh more
advanced building across Europe and
Canada so we are in a totally different
place uh I remember we were in 2014 when
things were going down now they went up
and and they were doing a significant
job defense spending so of course we
identity we a new defensiveness
investment
into account in fact I believe in all
dangerous uh world
um
so what I will argue in favor was that
when we refer to two percent in the
pledge we waited we made in ways other
than NATO Center events in 2014 we
referred that to something which
described Wars more like a kind of a
ceiling and now we should refer to two
percent more as a floor a minimum uh and
of course then we had a kind of a
10-year perspective
um
2014-2024. now I think we should be also
understand that this is going to
immediately uh to be there and we are
now 10 years already to move towards two
percent so I expect actually they're out
there that the majority of allies will
be able to be a few percent very quickly
thank you very much Secretary General
I'm just returning to uh the issue of
China
um have you had do you have any more
information on whether China is planning
or is actually supplying arms to Russia
for the war in Ukraine and
more specifically what is your message
to president G as he meets with a leader
who has now accused of committing War
crops
so first
uh we haven't seen any proof that China
is delivering little weapons to Russia
but we have seen some signs that this
has been a request from Russia and that
this is an issue that is is
considered
in Beijing or by the Chinese authorities
and therefore our message has been that
China should not provide legal aid to to
Russia that will be to support an
individual war and when we clone the war
and support the legal innovation of
Ukraine Why by Russia got some data
China of course not
um
then of course a meeting that takes
place in Moscow is part of a part that
we have seen over the last years where
China and Russia are coming closer and
closer we have to remember that just
a couple of weeks or a few weeks before
the invasion last February president XI
and President Putin met in Beijing where
they signed the joint declaration
promising each other a partnership with
all any limits um and uh obviously how
China and Russia are coming closer
closer to the Metro domain the joint
exercises joint patrols Naval Air
Patrols in the economic domain and also
in the political and diplomatic domain
so the meeting in Moscow is part of that
pattern where China and Russia are
working more and more closely and
building this longer and stronger
partnership
how do you see and of course also
comment the latest development in the
relations between Serbia and of course
who are especially after this awkward
meeting of both leaders
well uh so I welcome the agreement and
the
thing how is the full implementation the
speed and full
reputation of agreement between
belgarde and ambition and of course we
strongly support the EFS infected
dialogue we enable Amazon Enterprise
political support we have been a close
contact
with the EU but also with Krishna and
balgar and of course we support also
the efforts to find a peaceful solution
through our care provision
close to 4 000 NATO troops in Kosovo
which are key to to to facilitate and
and support the political process so we
welcome the agreement
the message is that it has to be fully
and and quickly implemented by all
parties
two questions the first is for
clarification as Hungary formally agreed
to another meeting of the NATO Ukraine
commission and the second one is some
ammunition yesterday EU foreign and
defense ministers took the decision to
provide Ukraine with one million
artillery shells within 12 months
um commissioner returns also working
with industry to get around bottlenecks
in the production hoping to speed it up
I'm just wondering what specifically is
NATO's role in speeding up delivery and
production of artillery shells What
specifically can NATO do thank you
uh
first on the on the on the on the
speeding of delivery because we NATO has
many tasks so first of all
it's also set the guidelines and we
started last year to revise our
guidelines and not least for battle the
size of our mission which includes a few
results to ensure that allies started to
ramp up production both to replenish the
stock price which they have repeated to
provide support to Ukraine but of course
also to be able to continue to to
deliver
supported to to Ukrainian we've happened
to the defense industry and we met with
our armored directors and and the
message was AKA Iran called for
production and how well called that all
the D7 hours have signed contracts of
course that is a national decision to
sign their concrete contracts with the
industry but we also do I have done for
many years including all nomination we
have we are doing joint procurement
partly with groups of NATO allies but
also through the NATO support under
government agency so joint procurement
is something we have done for many years
so we'll continue to do joint
procurement including all our nation for
instance and Spain I was working on both
we had a project both on artillery but
also air defense
ammunition and all the types of
ammunition so of course was the fact
that EU is now also engaging in joint
procurement uh but the most important
thing is not whether the joint
requirement is a group of Nations or EU
or the NATO procurement agency or when
it's done by individual allies the most
important thing is that contracts are
sound within the sole production can be
increased and we are all in this scene
more contrast to be inside and we
welcome all the different initiatives in
different formats for joint procurement
because we think that can help to speed
up and also utilize the economy of scale
but again it happens a little for us
including
through the NATO support and repair
agency
so far enable allies have
have delivered a meter Support over uh
65 billion
euros
a lot of that also in the United States
but also Canada and European allies are
providing significant militias reported
to to Ukraine and this is not least
to finance the delivery of amnition
and of course I always try to have
allies to agree but when we cannot fully
read them it's still my priority to
recommend a meeting so not that they
found something in different departments
and and how I do that
foreign
in Sweden so first of all I
I'm absolutely confident that also
Sweden will become a full member of this
Alliance
second it is a top priority with me
meaning that I really believe that it
will be good for NATO it will be good
for Finland it will soon it will be good
for all of us and to have a financially
in as equipment as possible that's also
the reason why I work hard to get
agreement uh uh last year which was
historic uh decision at all made by us
also turkey 100 remain to invite
financially and since then since uh
since uh June last year we are at the
quickest accession process in Edo's
modern history because we have to
remember that financially the problem
made only in June they were invited and
since then financially has had a totally
new position in England because they now
have the position as equities meaning
that they sit at the NATO table we
integrate in Finland swedenborough
researchers and this integration process
will take some time rebuild their
planning we can build tutorials and and
that integration process has not been
postponed uh behind uh the fact that the
ratification has taken a bit more time
than we hoped so so the main integration
goes on regardless of in a way
the fact that hergary and uh and and
turkey has not ratified because part of
being by t means that you have in
integrated into NATO's military searches
including interim a capability targets
so the military planning integration
process is something which is moving on
uh not delayed by
the gratification process
second is that for me this is a topology
unit has spent
sort of ideable I could have together
with with President the southern
minister with at that time uh prime
minister
and and the new government in Sweden
we're continuing to work together closer
to ensure the agreement and the
invitation and now the integration into
enables severeign
I went to
I think it's now
three four weeks ago we had a meeting
with the president adron and that was
the meeting where we may declare that he
is ready to or turkey is ready to ratify
Finland
and I welcome that as you now see
a progress on the application of Finland
and hopefully that will happen very soon
then on Sweden president early on in a
meeting agreed to restart the process
and also in meetings of uh what we call
the permanent mechanism were Finland
Sweden turkey meet and they met under my
old species of the data reporters a few
days ago and That Was Then led to the
foreign announcement of the
decision to move on with the
ratification of Finland but of course in
that meeting we also then are able to
address how to make progress on the
ratification of Sweden and will continue
to meet I spoke again with uh with the
president on Friday and we again agreed
to continue the consultations and the
meetings to ensure that we could also
make a progress on the ratification of
of Sweden then I spoke this morning with
the president with the foreign minister
of Hungary
and and he also confirmed that there
will be a vote on the 27th of March on
in the in the Hungarian Parliament on
the notification of Finland and we'll
continue then tomorrow on progress
making progress on the certification of
the students
thank you
Ukraine commission Secretary General is
it means that we can see from now on
that such kind of meeting will take
place regularly on the regular basis and
even that participation of the president
Ukrainian President
also will take a place in this format
like the Ukraine commission and second
question is don't you think that time
came to denounce native Russia room
agreement which will established also
NATO Russia Council thank you
NATO has worked for Meaningful dialogue
with the Russia of many many years
Russia has walked away from that island
so that's not functioning it it is not
possible to have a meaningful title with
Russia when they are conducting a legal
War aggression against the Ukraine but
we use the NATO Russia Council
after the invasion we have to remember
that we actually met in this building
in January and just a few weeks before
the nation to try to convince and to try
to use all the Diplomatic analytical
judgments to prevent a person who did
Russia for from uh implementing to to
follow through on their plans to invade
the Ukraine so so the next Russia
Council was an important instrument in
our efforts to try to establish some
kind of meaningful dialogue with Russia
we used it to try to prevent the
invasion of Ukraine but since the
invasion this has no meaning uh don't
have any meaningful dialogue with a
country that is responsible for a
illegal War aggression against the
neighbor Ukraine so so we don't have
meetings of course in this Council now
then when it comes to the native Ukraine
Council we
this is this is a established framework
I have learned that you convenient and I
have in respect for the the issues that
Hungary has raised I have not convened
that for some time but now I will
continue to convince the the meetings of
the of the NATO Ukraine Council the
commission sorry and and I will start
with a meeting at the foreign
ministerial meeting I've not planned any
more meetings other process will not be
one-off event it will continue to have
meetings when it comes to that the
summit we are not decided to finally in
the performance but I have medical
good luck
I just want to follow up on the the
question about Sweden's ratification do
you still expect Sweden to be ratified
by both turkey and Hungary by Vilnius
and then secondly on
um the question about uh make fighter
jets Poland and Slovakia pledge what
impact do you expect this to have on the
battlefield and have any allies Express
concern about these deliveries
especially with regards to escalation
thank you
but on on Finland based on what has been
announced both from of Hungary and
turkey and the two others are not yet
ratified the Finnish accession protocol
uh I I expect that they can become
members before the
um the Turkish election because
because
Vote or this is a in the in the in the
Hungarian parliament of the 27th of
March so that's our base what I said
what they have publicly said there's
Medicaid a plan is to
ratify before the Turkish Parliament
goes into recess ahead of the Turkish
election of course I cannot guarantee
National involvements National foreign
was a careful multiple speaking on
behalf of parliaments parliaments are
serving all this they make their own
decisions but at least that's what has
been announced and I based on those
plans and those announcements uh Finland
will be remembered very soon and before
the Turkish elections or before the
Turkish Parliament because they do
recess based on what they have said and
then on Sweden
I will not give you any exact dates but
I will just tell that this is a top
priority and I work hard to ensure that
also the Sweden uh becomes a full member
uh gratification process can be found as
as soon as possible that's reason why I
I traveled to Hong Kong that's the
reason why I also spends some time in in
Stockholm in Helsinki and also
convenient that the
therapal permit mechanism here and will
continue to engage with all these
countries to ensure that we have the
quickest possible classification also of
of all three
answer
classes yeah
yes that's right
Secretary General in the Mediterranean
migration is reaching level unseen since
the 2015 crisis Italy as recently
recently linked to this phenomenon on
wheeling intentional rational
destabilization strategy and as you
notice the dating concept states are 360
degrees approach to security and see the
map as a political Theater now the
question is do you accept that the
southern border can be at risk because
of migration used as a hybrid weapon and
these are NATO ready to do more in uh in
that area and secondly even in a
um would you be available for a second
mandate I mean propagation again of your
mandate Maybe
first on the south
um while NATO has a significant presence
in the Mediterranean and in the South to
address instability to fight the
terrorism and also support efforts of
the European Union to deal with the
illegal migration we for instance have
enabled presence in the Aegean Sea to
help to implement the the agreement
between turkey and the European Union on
illegal immigration I've been there
since for several years I was working
with partners and like
Mauritania like Tunisia and others to
help them build their defense and
security institutions to stabilize their
own country so that's the distribute
causes of the migration challenge
so we are working in many different ways
and of course we also see that we see
increased Russian presence you know the
in the south Africa notice to the Barney
group so I think that they've just
highlights that NATO doesn't have the
luxury of choosing either
focus on one or the other challenge of
that we Face to be able to deal with all
of them at the same time of course there
are a different nature and different
intensity but NATO has to deal with them
at the same time and also a lot of what
we do on critical infrastructure is also
related to the South there are cables
there are this infrastructural system
and training but of course NATO is a
military Alliance we have our tools and
the European Union International
Nations have all the tools so we don't
we don't have all the tools so that's
all the issues related to the migration
but we support efforts of the European
Union and and individual allies in
different ways and will continue to do
so another step of our work with
partners for instance over in Africa and
also in Iraq I met with Iraqi Iraqi
foreign minister yes
the Imaging Georgia
thank you very much Mrs Secretary
General two questions about Georgia
first as we are waiting for the new
Summit
this summer and for more support from
NATO what can you tell us more about it
and overall evaluation of 2022 and also
can you comment on this developments in
Georgia I mean um
presentation in Georgian Parliament a
foreign agent draft and in two days it
was voted down so can you comment on
this thank you very much so I welcome
the decision by the Georgia Department
or to withdraw the draft law on foreign
influence or foreign agents because it's
compatible with
eurodactic values and the protection of
Financial Freedom so I welcome that this
proposal was withdrawn not supported by
the
parliament in the BC I encourage
Georgia's political leaders to work
together on reforms urgently needed and
of course also worked with the
government of Georgia to implement these
reforms
to strengthen and classic institutions
to strength
services and also to fight a corruption
the Georgian people have made it very
fair that they want a democratic
prosperous Georgia that is integrated
into the Euro Atlantic region and it
will continue to be a partner to those
aspirations
we've talked a lot about Ukraine
understandably the focus of the alliance
has been has been there for the in
recent months
are you keeping focus on Russia's
activities in the high North and how
will the membership I mean the eventual
membership of Sweden and Finland changed
the dynamic on the north of Bank of the
events
The Finnish and Swedish membership will
strengthening in many different ways
first of all it will strengthen the
whole night and because financing has
have capable Armed Forces well trained
well equipped and modern uh armed forces
and uh and we have worked together with
Finance with many years
have enabled Nan and Air Forces which
are highly capable and will help us also
to increase our presence our awareness
also in the high North and of course
both people in Sweden are Arctic Nations
they know how to operate under Army
conditions and then also not least
increase our ability to reduce by the
airspace in the in the high North and
operate across the borders uh in in
Norwich region so yes that is important
for Ohio North
but of course also for instance for the
multi countries if you just look at the
map you will see that reinforcement the
protection of the Baltic region will be
very different and and it will be a much
better place to do that with the Finland
and Sweden and therefore welcome the
fact that allow us and invited them to
the funeral very soon be your divide
based on what has been announced from uh
Lopez and then we will I will continue
to work hard for the quickest possible
application of also of Sweden then the
heart of has mattered for uh NATO for
many years and therefore we have a
significant presence there we have
several hours
which are Arctic Nations including
Iceland
we have presence in Iceland with
NATO planes
Eisen is important also when it comes to
monitoring
following the Russian military movements
of the lower North their their
submarines their ships their their
planes and Allah
investing in new online capabilities
including Advanced fifth generation
fighter aircraft so that was
significantly increase our
capability so important monitoring and
surveillance over what's going on in the
high air North
more ships we have more exercises and I
just last week I went together with
a person who saw otherwise much better
to uh well the gas facilities the gas
spot for patrol platform in North Sea
which is important for Norway for the
Nordic region but of course also for
energy supplies to Europe 10 of Europe's
gas supplies comes from that one
platform so of course enabled also
stepping up what they do to protect
critical infrastructure this is also a
very much about the high North so yes
High North is has been will continue to
be a very importance for NATO that was
added climate change to make the high
North even more important the ice is
melting and it's possible to operate
there
more throughout the year and uh and that
also increase the Strategic importance
of the lineup thank you very much I know
there are more questions
now however you can pick up a hard copy
of the annual report on your way out and
hope to see as many of you as possible
at the annual media reception
thank you thank you okay